En jaune et rouge des filles du club de l'ouest
tourangeau face en bleu et jaune aux jocondiennes.
Pour la plupart des joueuses les crampons ont été
chaussés car le foot était une passion familiale
parmi des dix-huit mille licenciés en
indre-et-loire 2500 sont des filles et
ces dix dernières années les inscriptions
au féminin ne cesse de grimper : la passion
est grandissante "j'aimerais bien
être footballeuse professionnelle"
(comment on fait pour être footballeuse
proffessionelle ?) "ben faut travailler dur".
"ma passion et peut-être mon
futur métier si j'y arrive"
sur les 190 arbitres de la ligue du centre
seules 11 femmes. Le district veut ainsi miser
sur cette formation pour les jeunes filles en
indre-et-loire. 200 femmes se sont positionnées
sur des directions de club et ce chiffre ne cesse
d'augmenter. Le foot féminin se développe et les
préjugés sont mis de côté par la jeune génération.
"C'est mieux qu'il y a quelques années,
le foot féminin il se développe de plus en plus
et puis bah comme on devient quand même des ados,
c'est moins... les garçons sont un peu
plus mature etc... c'est moins tabou".
"Mais franchement moi quand je
le dis, ils disent ok c'est bien"
Mais ce développement du football féminin
pourrait trouver ses limites dans les
infrastructures : accueillir filles et garçons
dans un même club, c'est proposer des vestiaires
dédiés, ce qui n'est pas le cas partout.
" Aujourd'hui on demande à nos politiques
d'augmenter les capacités d'accueil pour
pouvoir justement accompagner ce développement
du football féminin et comme le sport féminin
que ce soit le football ou les autres sports
de balle notamment, et bien écoutez, par
nos politiques on espère être entendus"
Autre requête du district, développer ses
infrastructures pas seulement sur la métropole,
mais dans le milieu rural :
le vivier du foot au féminin